John Hein was picky about food in LA the
show meaning our show in LA was so
classy we had catered lunches from
Sunday through Wednesday it was the most
amazing thing what was up with Jason
what and Jason's of food nuts oh my god
I was on the what was in the catering so
first of all every morning huge
breakfast so you show up and anything
you want if you're into bread they had
the bagels and the muffins and the toast
dad eggs they had eggs with cheese they
had everything you could ask for home
fries everything all the meats all the
meats the Bacon's the sausages the
turkey saw turkey sausages cereal if you
ask me Jason what else can we put out
here to eat I'm at nothing you got it
you got a comment nice it's beautiful
right and in lunch every day they had a
different theme so there was Mexican day
chinese-food day Italian day
Mediterranean day so what does John do
so here I'm on Sunday it turns out that
John just was not happy about lunch like
canards they were yeah providing could
not fight now which is absurd it was
absurd that was Mexican day I believe so
John tried to go to Pink's hot dogs for
lunch but the line was too long he
reluctantly ate the Mexican food we
served you were really like on Tuesday
instead of the Chinese food you were
give him for lunch John went to
Fatburger on Wednesday instead of the
Italian food we were served John went to
McDonald's and it's not even California
to like I mean you're like a baby you're
just hot dogs and hamburgers well have
like no I'm surprised she's like a
sophisticated guy no palette couple of
things one with the breakfast I actually
ate the breakfast every day and it was
really nice and and of course I
appreciate everything that was done but
in going through the line and looking at
the different things that were out there
it just didn't appeal to me that's the
whole John basically only eats
hamburgers and hot dogs in the six days
he was in Los Angeles
he went to in and out three times that
burger twice and Pink's hot dogs once at
McDonald's months at the SiriusXM party
John bypassed Nobu sushi being served by
chef Nobu himself and it's
had three hot dogs you know at Nobu
they've got like steak they've got
they've got chicken that wasn't an
option at the serious event and I didn't
know the chef Nobu sorry
so people were giving me looks like I'm
crazy because you had to walk like that
all the way down the corridor and they
had a little Pink's section and that was
the place I wanted to go to where I
couldn't get to the first day I feel bad
for you in a way I mean it's like you
Nanak's you're not opening up to great
things in life but I don't I don't feel
that way I feel like I enjoy the other
stuff so much like to me that's my like
in and out is my Nobu in a way like I
like going there so much I think it's so
good